castle point and rochard health and
wellbeing strategy reset
community resilience workshop from the
9th of september 2020
facilitated by sarah mills who is a
locality
development manager at castle point and
rochford clinical commissioning group
scene setting for this new priority area
the 2020 code 19 pandemic
has presented unprecedented challenges
as to how we live together as residents
and work together in our communities
district and borough councils were asked
to mobilize residents
and join up with key community leaders
and partners to provide a response to
meet the needs
of the most vulnerable in our
communities this challenge was met both
as a county and as districts
and the data from operation shield
presented on the following slides
reflects that response this pandemic has
again
highlighted the importance of our
community's ability to respond to change
to care for each other and themselves
and to be connected into wider networks
at times of difficulty
this community resilience has been an
underlying theme in much of the
system-wide thinking about new ways of
working at a more local level
this is highlighted in work such as the
primary care networks and e-put
community health services delivery model
to support integration and deliver new
ways of locality working
based on population health and local
need
these developments have created the
appetite across the ball to ensure that
this is a new distinct area for
consideration
and a standalone theme in our new health
and wellbeing strategy
questions to consider as you look at the
data one
what does the data tell us two what are
the key themes identified
three what is the current situation and
what might the near future look like for
residents given the effects of covert 19
has had on community resilience sarah
mills commented saying
obviously the data set that we have for
community resilience is somewhat limited
because it's a new priority area we
don't have that historical collection of
data
also it's much more difficult to
quantify community resilience is a
little bit more intangible
qualitative and a bit more about
perceptions than facts
operations shield what the data tells us
the
data collected by essex county council
as part of operation shield tells us
the number of extremely vulnerable or
category a residents
there are in each district and borough
how many of these had registered on the
government portal to indicate what
needs they had how many people sought
help from the essex welfare service and
local community hubs during the
coronavirus pandemic
the type of help requested for example
with getting food
medicines befriending or healthy
lifestyle advice
and where in each district and borough
their requests came from by ward
and an age breakdown operation shield
summary headlines
a large volume of support has been
offered to residents across essex
by the essex welfare service and local
community hubs in each district
a total of 889 people have contacted the
community hubs to date
in castle point and rochford 319
and 570 respectively
861 contacts have been made to the essex
welfare service across castle point and
rockford
577 and 284 respectively
75 referrals were made from the essex
welfare service the community hub in
castle point
and 39 were made to the rochford hub
this data was taken from essex county
council operations shield dashboard
requests for help in castle point of the
4727 extremely vulnerable or category a
residents in castle point
2763 or 58.5
had registered on the government portal
to indicate what needs they had
the most requests for help came from
james's ward
of the 75 referrals from essex welfare
service to the community hub
68 were for food one was for befriending
and six for other support the majority
of these 75 referrals were for people
aged 65 to 74.
sarah mills commented on this saying i
think there's that understanding that we
know who some of these people
are but we don't know who all of them
are
requests for help in the rocha district
after 5737 extremely vulnerable or
category a residence in the rocha
district
3246 or 57
were registered on the government portal
to indicate what needs they
had the most request for help came from
trinity ward
of the 39 referrals from essex welfare
service to the rochford community hub
35 were for food two referrals worth of
medicine
and two for other support 15 of the 39
referrals were for people aged 75 plus
14 four people aged 65 to 74 years
and 10 for 18 to 64 years
sarah mills asked are those unregistered
vulnerable people really difficult to
find
to help and to offer support to
referrals to essex welfare service
a total of 9211 contacts have been made
to the essex welfare service today
across the whole of essex
of these 577 have come from castle point
and 284 from rochford a breakdown by
ward shows that the greatest number of
referrals within castle point came from
canvay island north
in the rochwood district the greatest
number of referrals came from hockley
help with getting food was the main
reason for referral in both areas
a breakdown by age ban shows that the
majority of contacts made the essex
welfare service
from both castle point and rockford
where residents aged 75 plus
discussion reflecting on the data sarah
mills asked the group to share their
faults in response to their
experience over the last few months of
the community and voluntary offer
locally
and whether the data looked familiar to
those present
discussion points scott williamson
discussed that
isolation and vulnerability among people
is very evident
who don't feel able for whatever reason
to connect into the service we have in
our community
i'd love to know why that is julie
salford said
lots of older people believe they do not
need help and would prefer
services to go to people that genuinely
need it
sarah mills explained that the total
offer is greater than the sum of its
parts
she also commented saying we need to
make sure everyone has a voice and the
needs that they recognise were as
important as health needs
and social care needs scott williamson
commented saying
i think the key thing for us is we
worked in partnership
that was really helpful we had the
council we had the community
we had churches we had volunteers i
think that was really powerful
victoria mazuki added the discussion
saying we would not have had the
success of the hub and helped the people
if it was not a partnership approach
we couldn't have done it ourselves the
partnership is the strength
sarah mills concluded this part of the
conversation by saying
so in terms of the strategy one of the
essential tenets of community resilience
is partnership working regarding the
essex county council data showing
unemployment levels due to covid and
furlough
councillor webb commented in rochford
we've not had that level of unemployment
before
and maybe that feeds into people not
wanting to accept help because as a
district we've not been in that position
before
whereas other parts of the county have
been in that position before
and yet now we've got that same issue to
some extent in rochefort
i think that's where the community
struggles to adapt to being in a
different
place to where it has been before
sarah mills asked how do you think
that's going to impact on what the
community needs from not
only its statutory services but also its
voluntary services
victoria mazuki responded saying future
work has
got to be food banks as they're not the
norm what can we do to build people
through budgeting
apprenticeships offering them
volunteering and upskilling
so that they have the ability to find
work when it's available
and what can we do to support them with
for example cooking courses to be able
to make them not reliant on food banks
scott williamson commented saying what
we're looking at is how do we train
people
how can we help people out of this
crisis going forward what are the needs
that come up
why do people go to the food banks we're
looking to put a program together to
deliver on some of that
he also added that it would be
beneficial from both sides to linking
with some of the partners of local gp
practices
in the southeast essex locality strategy
the overall system ambition is to
improve the well-being and lives of the
people we serve focus on prevention and
supporting the strengths of communities
and individuals
prioritize the needs and locations of
people rather than the boundaries of
organizations
and work with each other and the local
population to organize services
and mobilize resources within
communities
underlying principles agreed for south
east essex are as follows
locality first thinking driving this at
an organizational level
population health management which
includes prevention personal
empowerment and community resilience
co-production which will facilitate
local people
to be involved in all levels of
developing implementing
reviewing and assessing the new models
of care sharing of resource
which will implement and support the
wide transformation of the system
and communications and engagement which
are system-wide and cross-locality
our ambition for locality leadership
sarah mills then presented the vision
for locality leadership that has come
out of conversation with a variety of
healthcare partners and others
the overall ambition is to have leaders
from community organizations
alongside residents and faith leaders
committed to improving health and
well-being
as well as health and social care
workers and mental health practitioners
who together have a collective
leadership function the leadership
function is as follows
identifying and sharing a common purpose
reviewing current collaborative working
engineering opportunities to build
multi-agency relationships
building the foundations for a locality
integrated network
reviewing data and identifying
priorities identifying workforce gaps
and development needs
creating a culture of quality
improvement and initial
signal point of escalation for
partnership working
sarah mills then explained that this
locality leadership would direct the
strategy and formalize partnership
working
recognising that the work that the
community sector can do
can happen more upstream and prevent
some of those crises
and urgent care needs happening
managing the needs of a locality
population for a tiered approach
this is thinking about how we provide a
support on a local population level
for example benfleet or canby or oxford
to meet a breadth of needs
this idea can be illustrated in a
pyramid whereby the level of need is
inversely proportional to the size of
the population
at the top of the pyramid are the people
who have the highest needs
who need health and social care and a
whole host of services
and wrap around support then there are
those who have ongoing
care needs this could be people who may
be frail
or have one or more long-term condition
and need regular interface with their gp
and or hospital services then there are
people with urgent care needs where
people
have a health event or health crisis
such as a stroke
and need a lot of support for a short
period of time
the idea is that if the urgent care need
is met effectively
they can move into the bottom whole
population tier of the pyramid
sarah mills explained that the bottom
population tier is where community
resilience comes in
it really focuses on that prevention
agenda supporting people to take healthy
behaviors
making sure that planning decisions are
mindful of health and well-being needs
health promoting environments and
infrastructures
such as active travel for example she
added that this
is where this element of the health and
well-being strategy really focuses
on that whole population asset-based
prevention and creating healthy
environments for people to lead healthy
lives within
that leadership model could help to
drive this and make sure that all
partners are working together
so that a breadth of need can be met
sarah mills then asked the group for
their thoughts on this kind of model
and how the respective local
organizations could play a part to bring
that into being
the key things for this discussion was
sustainability of the community
partnership approach and isolation
ben brook started off this discussion
saying there is something around
coordination and where that coordination
takes place is something we need to get
to the bottom of
is the gp surgery the first place people
go when they want to talk to somebody
i think it's about community sector
navigation to understand what that local
offer is
and what each organization does perhaps
not initially
but since lockdown there is a lot more
communication between the community and
voluntary organizations
which was really powerful julie sulfur
continued the discussion by saying
it's not just health it's wherever
anybody goes to get some support
with families it might be the school or
people with preschoolers the family hubs
even if it's just a poster on the wall
in the library
julie sawford added that there's also an
element of can we rely on
smaller organizations to always be there
as a partnership we're really strong and
only getting stronger
so the partnership is what is able to
support the community
rather than the individual organizations
within that
victoria mazuki continued the
conversation saying i think it's about
getting the message out to places where
people go
people don't want the help people don't
want to ask for help
but people need the help places where
people go where they will get the
information
but they don't have to find it or make
it more obvious people usually only
approach a voluntary sector when in
crisis
or when they already know about them
lindsey gillingham
added this saying someone has to be
ready to accept help
we've got to be mindful of not having
too much information out in the
community
so people don't get confused she
continued by saying
as a cvs we've already got a membership
base
if we can't personally help we know
someone who can the strength
is our partnership work and the
collaborative working
other factors to acknowledge are wider
determinants of health and health
inequalities for example built a natural
environment work vulnerability income
crime education and skills direct and
indirect effects of covering 19 for
example end of furlough scheme and the
potential rise in
unemployment debt family tensions
housing evictions cognitive decline lack
of social interaction
plus mobilizing resources again in the
event of a second wave
next steps as a group is there other
data you can share to inform and provide
more insight
does anyone else need to be involved we
will meet as a subgroup between now and
december to continue our discussions
develop the narrative around this
priority and start thinking about some
actions
how we are tackling the problems and
what other actions would help us to
address them in terms of early
intervention and prevention
and think about assets within the castle
point and rockford